[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof first off we would like
to thank our members that helped us to
produce these videos and keep them both
free on YouTube thank you very much and
if you would like to become a member you
can follow the instructions down in the
links that we provide below hello Walter
hi it's nice to see you again and we've
had some comments in our previous video
videos that were mentioning Bible
translations and you've been on the
carpet a few times because of your views
on the Bible translations now there's
also been people saying that you are a
King James only man and I would like to
discuss all of these issues with you in
this episode but would you please pray
for us and open this because it's
necessary to have the work of the Holy
Spirit with us let's pray our loving
Heavenly Father your word is a lamp unto
our feet and a light unto our path and
therefore it is important that we tread
softly when it comes to this issue and
therefore I pray that you will be with
us and enlighten us with your Holy
Spirit in Jesus name Amen
well you said I was a king James only
men well let me put it quite pertinently
I'm not a king James only man I am a
received text only man there's a vast
difference because there are numerous
translations out there in the world that
are based on the received text and so
what was the Bible that Martin Luther oh
yes oh by the way there's a beautiful
example on the shelf over there of that
massive Bible of Martin Luther's and
it's old and moldy and so full of
beautiful pictures and things it's it's
a wonderful word that's based on the
received text so how can I be a King
James only person if they survived what
was written in my mother tongue so let's
get rid of that misconception right off
the bat the issue is is very complex
it's a very deep issue and it's a very
emotional issue and so in order to do it
justice we have to approach it carefully
the question is what do we believe about
this marvelous book this is the King
James Version which is my current Bible
and it wasn't always my current Bible
okay I started off with the NIV
and I studied the NIV and I have about
two n IVs that are totally
disintegrating and it is through a
process of of let's say growth that I
realized that there were so many
anomalies in these translations
that I moved on to a Bible that was more
based on the received text and that
happened to be the New King James so I
have a number of New King James which
have gone through a similar process and
eventually I am now at receive text in
the King James Version now why is that
and why this progression modern
translations and this is by the
admittance of the publishers and the
committee's that reduce them or what we
call eclectic texts now an eclectic text
takes information from various thinkers
from all over the world and collects
them and this becomes to them what the
Word of God says now how do we approach
the Word of God is it an inspired book
man does not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of the Lord of so we must know you
know is this the Word of God yes now an
eclectic text can contain the Word of
God
hmm but that doesn't mean that it is the
Word of God
I would like to know what did God say
and not what did someone think God said
yes there's a vast difference and if we
if we look at the approach that we have
in the world out there there are
thousands of different varieties of what
people think God said so it's like
getting things secondhand third-hand and
via how many sources and eventually you
don't know what was God's Word and what
was not God's Word so I want to have a
Bible that is a direct translation of
what God said if
I want to know what some particular
individual be respected or not in the
world has to say I can always go and
look it up in his comments on the Bible
or in a Bible commentary but first and
foremost I want to know what did God say
yes and then I want to be able to
communicate with the God that I believe
inspired this book and say to him lord
help me to understand this book I want
to know what you have said and if I base
my study on that then I can trust in the
fact that the Holy Spirit will help me
if I get stuck with something in the
counsel of many there is wisdom and I
can look at what various people have to
say about these issues but I want to
know what he said now there's one thing
to say that this book is inspired but
inspiration without preservation is
totally useless
because if the original autograph was
inspired and it wasn't preserved then
how do I know that this is the Word of
God
yes it could be gobbly goop right now I
want to know is this the inspired Word
of God now are there not promises in the
Bible where the Bible clearly tells us
this is not only an inspired book where
holy men were moved by the Spirit of God
but that it is a preserved book and it's
a covenant and it's a covenant now this
is very important now a covenant is an
agreement between parties and this book
the Bible is a covenant between God and
man
and we need to know exactly what this
covenant entails and who is affected by
the covenant so let us say that the
Bible is not only the thoughts of God
it's not only the words of God but it is
a legal document it is a covenant and
legal documents have certain criteria
for example if you purchase a property
can you just purchase the property or
must there be witnesses to witness to
the fact that you have covenant to
purchase this property yes there must be
witnesses all right is one witness
enough no no you have to have more than
one witness at least two so even the
Bible says by two word of two or three
witnesses every word shall be
established so you need witnesses so a
legal document has witnesses what else
does a legal document have to have it
has to have very precise information as
to exactly who is involved in this legal
document if you for example set up a
world and you're very vaguely talked
about how everything is to be
distributed it'll be very confusing to
those who actually have to implement the
world right so how precise must it be
you must know exactly who it is
referring to and who is being spoken
about now in in high court legal
documents very often they are written in
a very specific way it's interesting
that in some of these very important
legal documents I'm not talking about
general legal issues on you know public
level I'm talking about
really important high court issues for
example there's no punctuation
interesting yes because a comma in the
wrong place can influence a person to
think in a particular direction yeah
whereas if there is no punctuation then
you have to defer or infer from the
information that is provided who the
parties are without prejudice a
beautiful example in the Bible is verily
verily I say unto you today you shall be
with me in the kingdom of heaven or
verily verily I say unto you today you
will be in the kingdom of heaven the
comma is is very important as to where
it is placed because it changes the
entire theology now the original
autographs didn't have that kind of
punctuation so that is precisely what
you would find in a legal document now
why do I like the King James I first
that carefully I'm not a king James only
yes but why do I like the King James I
like the King James because it is
phrased in this legal language besides
having a legal language it is also a
poetic language it is probably the
greatest literary masterpiece ever
written and it has it has managed to
retain some of the beauty of the Hebrew
and the parallelism parallelism and the
poetry that goes along with it and there
is no other translation that has
retained it as the King James has not
only that it because it is a
word-for-word translation with
the retention of the poetic structure
which is which isn't itself Amer America
you can have chiastic yes structures and
chiastic structures are often based on
repetition yes to to fit in certain
ideas and to highlight certain portions
of the scripture and the Hebrew is is
totally written in caius restructure the
Bible in fact in the old and the New
Testament has these attributes and now
there are people that say that the King
James or the received text is an
expanded text yes correct
now why is it an expanded text because
the manuscripts that the modern
translations are based upon our shorter
alright so are they now the criterion or
is the other one the criterion why don't
we ever hear people say the modern ones
are reduced text no this is an expanded
text so the other one automatically
becomes the norm what if it's the other
way around
well they what if this is the original
and the other one is a shrunken text why
would they be so many repetitions for
example if you go to the book of
Revelation and it talks about I am the
Alpha and the Omega and it has a lot of
things and it ends with I am the Alpha
and the Omega many modern people say
what this is needless repetition and
take it out once is enough well excuse
me
you have just destroyed the chiasm yes
by removing it so is the expanded one
the correct one or is the contracted one
the correct one in my opinion this is
not an expanded text this is the
reading text now what else is important
in a covenant well you were speaking now
about receive text yes what is the
difference between receive takes and the
texts that they use to to modern
translations although there are
basically two streams of manuscripts in
the world out there the one is the
Byzantium text and the other one is the
Egyptian Alexandrian texts and there are
about 45 manuscripts basically that they
have found in the deserts of Egypt and
it's amazing to me that people will say
that God has preserved his word in the
deserts of Egypt and we have now at the
end of time here dug them up and found
his word that is the most ridiculous
statement I have ever heard in my life
the Byzantine text is the text that was
used at Antioch for example where the
first church was and from there it
spread to the entire world even as far
as India and China and all of those and
and then made its way into Europe and
this was the text that was used by the
early church correct
now the Alexandrian version it was used
in Alexandria and in Rome yes and does
Rome now become the modern Harbor and
now that Alexandria no longer exists of
this word that was found in the desert
yeah now it does God preserve his word
in the desert sand for some future
generation to dig up in a moldy fashion
and read or does he preserve it by
implanting it in the minds of men
throughout every generation this is a
very important issue now because what
happened to the people in that period
that wasn't discovered in the desert so
without the text then God left them
without a witness that doesn't make any
and then who is the Habra of God's Word
is it the proud hierarchy in Rome or was
it or was it that the the Word of God
came via the Byzantines into Europe by
people that were closely associated with
the Apostles from the beginning and were
the ones who nurtured and kept the word
of God alive in in the minds of men and
who were prepared to die for that word
exact they had in their hands and you
know we have a source which is called
the spirit of prophecy and the spirit
prophecy tells us very clearly who were
the ones that had the Word of God
and adulterated it was the vault Indians
they would walk the foot wow so now
there's this argument oh but they you
know they are a very late arrival and
they talk about Peter Waldo and all this
no no they can be traced back to the
first and second century and you would
have to deny those writings in order to
change that view so perhaps I can read
to you a statement regarding this issue
here's one that comes from HF 45
Perigord 1 the vowed or churches
resembled the Church of apostolic times
rejecting the supremacy of the Pope and
prelate they held the Bible as the only
infallible Authority their pastors
unlike the lordly priests of Rome fed
the flock of God leaving them to green
pastures and living fountains of His
Holy Word the people assembled not in
magnificent churches or grand cathedrals
but in the alpine valleys or in time of
danger in some rocky stronghold to
listen to the words of truth from the
servants of Christ the pastor's not only
preached the gospel they visited the
singing labored to promote harmony and
broad
like Paul the tentmaker
each learned some trade by which if
necessary to provide for his own support
in paragraph 1 of page 43 it says their
religious belief was founded upon the
written word of God those humble
peasants shut away from the world had
not by themselves arrived at truth in
opposition to the dogmas of the apostate
Church their religious belief was their
inheritance from their fathers they
contended for the faith of the Apostolic
Church the church in the wilderness and
not the proud hierarchy enthroned in the
world's great capital was the Church of
Christ the guardian of the treasures of
truth which God committed to his people
to be given to the world so who were the
ones that had these manuscripts on which
they based the Word of God they were the
vault anciens so you have these two
streams and there are thousands of
documents that have been copied
painstakingly and carefully over
centuries which constitute the received
text of course because they were used
yes because they were incorporated into
the thinking of of men the original
autographs are not there and so now the
argument is well then they must be
faulty because by repeated copying they
must have been changed no but don't you
negate God's promise to preserve his
word then if you believe in inspiration
you must believe in preservation
absolutely now let's take a look at the
at the flagships of the Alexandrian line
yeah it's the Vaticanus and the
Sinaiticus now the one was found in the
library of the Vatican just in time to
refute the
the Bible version that Martin Luther
produced based on the received text and
on that you have the dua version yes
which is the Jesuit version and by the
way the Jesuits hated this word of God
they called it this poisonous ass and
they hated it with the passion yes and
they produced the UA which has Mary
crushing the head of the serpent
rather than Christ and it's a totally
spurious version and on that document on
the Vaticanus obviously was also based
the earlier Vulgate yes by Jerome and
then of course when this modern move
came they needed manuscripts other than
those to base their their translations
upon and then they found the Sinaiticus
yes in st. Catharines enormously yes and
Tischendorf found it there where did he
find it in just in a waste paper basket
now it's fascinating that sorry and he
also didn't find the complete one the
first time no it had to go back yes you
had to go back several times to discover
new management and why would this
Protestant dedicate it to the Pope yeah
this makes absolutely no sense to me
whatsoever and this this one was found
and it doesn't contain the first
portions of the Bible and it doesn't
contain the last portions of the Bible
the book of Revelation is completely
gone and I mean Westcott and Hort later
referred to these to the Vaticanus as an
ocean of purity when they found this
manuscript there were so many portions
that had been scratched out and changed
and rewritten the whole document was
plastered with changes now is this
indicative of God's word that is
changeless my opinion was that
it was found in a wastepaper basket and
it should have stayed there because that
is where in my opinion it belonged I
mean the Epistle of Barnabas the most
pathetic biological document I've ever
read in my life which has the iana
changing sex and and animals like the
weasel giving birth through the mouth I
mean if that is what is part of an
inspired document then the whole
document in my opinion is spurious but
the fact of the matter is that all
modern translations are basically based
on those two flagships with a couple of
uncles that have been found in those
deserts and two individuals Westcott and
Hort now it's fascinating to me that
these individuals were of course
Protestant and what a clever idea to use
Protestants to bring in this
documentation upon which modern Bibles
or based so they took basically those
two documents and produced a Greek text
for the New Testament upon which all
modern Bibles are based now these
gentlemen were as far removed from
Protestantism as the East is from the
West
in their own writings they condemn
themselves they were Mary ologists
number one they believed in evolution
they were evolutionists they despised
the received text they wrote in the most
derogatory fashion about their received
text and these are the documents on
which all modern Bibles are basically
based now let's go back to the King
James Bible which was the Protestant
version now I never started with the
King James the first translation was
Tyndall's translate
and Tyndale also like Martin Luther used
the received text and then this Bible
was taken together with other
manuscripts that came by the way from
the vault in ziens and in Geneva where
the Protestants were exiled they
produced the Bible transfer one of the
first ones by the way was the French
translation to which the Douay was
actually the counter and it was based on
vault Enzian manuscripts and the Geneva
Bible the English version was based on
Tyndall's translation and Coverdale and
and they produced the Geneva Bible which
was the bible of choice for protestants
for many many years in fact people were
very unincluded to give it up they loved
the Geneva Bible the Geneva Bible had a
problem for Catholicism though because
it had such very straightforward
footnotes and those footnotes revealed
exactly who was who in the zoo they made
no bones about calling the papacy
Antichrist for example and showing who
the little horn was etc or the beasts of
Revelation and the English also was Old
English like Chaucer English which was
and the English language had changed
considerably by the time you get to the
King James in 1611 and what happened was
that it was decided to make a
translation bringing it up to the more
modern English that was spoken
it's like Shakespearean English Alec at
that time and King James then gave the
permission not that he was such a
religious person but it's called the
King James because he gave permission
but there were to be no footnotes so
that's that's interesting in the
place but what what is interesting about
the King James is that the committee
that actually put it together they were
all Protestants yes and they were
believing Protestants and they believed
that this was the Word of God yes and
they had numerous translators and they
lived in various portions of the country
yes and when they when they translated a
verse then there had to be harmony in
the translations so that it was only
incorporated into the Bible if everybody
was on the same page
yes they won't cut often isolated they
could consult scholars it was even there
the public could absolutely in his input
yes it's amazing how it was put together
and they will tell us that this is a
cake language and this is a very
fascinating point and I would like us to
continue on that point in our next
episode
as our time is up for now we haven't
even started yes so that's why we have
to continue with this discussion thank
you for watching we will be back with
the next episode of what's up bro
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click yes when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time